ans baden denkt niemand mehr diese sich
kurz im ersten super mehr in england
südwesten
doch der ort hat aus heiterem himmel an
neue attraktion
hinter den mauern eines stillgelegten -
und ich will auch sehen was sich
dahinter versteckt schließlich strömen
derzeit täglich 4000 menschen hier hin
das abenteuer heißt disneyland was
bedeutet der name trostlos erwarten den
tag viel lächeln na dann viel spaß aber
lächeln scheint ihr trotz lustigem ort
fit verboten
die mitarbeiterinnen dieses amt die
vergnügungsparks wurden bestens geschult
nächste station sicherheitscheck bloß
stimmt etwas nicht
alles ist aus pappe und die kontrolleure
erinnern mich irgendwie monty python
nicht gleich nicht lachen vorwärts
stoppt ihr haben die tasche selbst
gepackt ich glaube ja drogen und waffen
ich glaube nein nein würde ich nie los
weiter das ist also die seltsame welt
von dessen welt so sieht sie aus und so
klingt sie
das kenne ich eine schießbude
was muss ich tun kann ich mal versucht
nein schade
auch ein schönes karussell steht da
fährt ein grübler geselle mit großartig
es hat genau die richtige dosis
trostlosigkeit
er findet mich ein sommerferien nur
hätten sich wohl damals nicht so viele
menschen freiwillig als idiot geortet
aber irritation ist schließlich das ziel
des parks und seine 50 beteiligten
künstler
er ist der initiator street-art-künstler
banksy aus dem nahen brüssel
in diesem niveau hat er schon als kind
den sommer verbracht und sich hier wohl
als kleiner selbst verewigt
seine identität hätte bis heute jedoch
gehalten
wechsel von banksy hat verschiedene
tiere
hier stehen die menschen schlange
weshalb wohl vielleicht weil das
märchenschloss an dessen elend erinnert
doch jemand hindert uns am weitergehen
soziale schon so richtig verwehrt
hier können wir aber nicht rein nicht da
rein auf den weg
diese security officer ist echt kamera
kein zutritt
so muss ich auf das offizielle werbe
wieder zurückgreifen
zu sehen ist eine umgekippte kutsche
cinderella verfolgt von einer meute
paparazzi eine derbe anspielung auf
prinzessin dianas tödlichen unfall in
paris
das ist alles recht zu passiv ist das
ein echtes interview ja wir sind von
echten fernsehen das trifft genau den
punkt jeder kann hier auf dich zukommen
du hast keine ahnung übersicht ist oder
teil der ganzen vorstellung
dazu passt auch diese attraktion farm
gesteuerte boote doch hier gefriert mir
das machen
polizeiboote jagen flüchtlings kutter
schiffe versenken makaber interpretiert
von bergsee
das ist alles so deprimierend
zeit also für einen kurzen moment der
erholung
das lido war einst stolz auf das größte
außenschwimmbecken europas längst
vergangene zeiten des moment soll der
region nun frischen wind einhauchen
ob es wirklich was wird bei all der
trostlosen stimmung zumal das projekt ja
einmalig und schon bald zu ende ist habe
ich jetzt vielleicht glück versuchen
amboss umwerfen zum zweiten
was kriege ich für drei treffer wie
keine preise mehr
das war also mein abenteuer trip ins
disneyland bank sie setzt damit der
gesellschaft ein trostloses manchmal
hässliche spiegelbild vor bloß der weg
hinaus führt auch hier zwingend durch
den geschenk shop heute hält einen
trostlosen tag